hello and welcome to this video playing
yaffa or java and we have the talent
game we can we please cancel short so
that I can I take you no no doesn't
comply always think this is totally
harmless it equal and then they out
clearly let's see is there something
something that I can do ripping at least
something he tries to do something okay
that should be really okay now right I
mean the night isn't even stable on 105
playing this to cover b7 by the Queen so
that loop t8 becomes possible
[Music]
Wow
Wow ok I take there he goes into five I
guess him d takes before that he takes
me five that doesn't do all that much ok
no it just takes on each for interesting
so this is putting it into a pin yeah
okay this is not ending up equal in some
way seems unlikely that time you don't
even though I'm a little bit more access
here a little bit more at least but
while the room only for is active for
him as well so it just take ok
it's still it's still extremely dry
I can put the book until c7 and does not
help at all it just stays in equal
position don't see any constructive idea
now this one okay choose which is what
it is it is equal
draw up a little after all Jim and this
opening is just utterly boring it's just
what it is very difficult to get
anything going okay maybe I should
shouldn't trade like all all the ships
but yet to do something from here is
really difficult and yeah there you
plate I mean I felt like maybe have
slight chances that this is a good move
it just kills of everything and I have
to play like that as really no no
nothing else Jim yeah probably this is
too simple too simplistic here it's
impossible to to play for for anything i
should probably somehow try to keep a
bit more tension but yeah against the
sterile play it's it's quite difficult
to do ok guys thanks so much